this is my report on the Soviet question
what's your answer I don't have one
the Kremlin is broke so how were the
Soviets suddenly on spending spree
arranging an interview with Stalin
garrets I've been trying to reach you go
see Walter Durant via the New York Times
listen I really need to talk to you I
found something take it you can't break
this door wide open Paul mr. Jones mr.
it's your auntie why are you really here
I need your help this is ADA Brooks
she's my star Paul's dead robbery three
days ago what do you want the story no
one is talking about I saw him for
pellets in his back and you don't think
it was a robbery what was Paul working
on Ukraine
how rich this country is how vast so
there's nothing but wheat fields grain
stalin's gold
I guess the agenda now I don't have an
agenda that's your call truth an agenda
yes but whose truth
what were you doing the others come
forward what's being done here will
transform mankind we can still do
something we cannot let Stalin get away
with this what do you expect me to do
exactly the Soviet Union is not the
worker's paradise that was promised it
is not the great experiment that you
read about in the press
[Music]
style is not the man who you think you
[Music]
he's saying this enough
[Music]
you